on y monte au petit jour encore
ensommeillé lui faire un brin de cours
on lui refait les poutrelles au milieu
des tourterelles on la Repin en répis
pas du sol au plafond mais jusqu'au
paradis nous sommes des estrillons des
artistes funambules ne cherchez pas les
vestibule il n'y a que du vent dans
toute la maison nous sommes des
papillons pris dans ses jolies dentelles
par Paris s'éveille tout en bas Paris ne
nous voit pas sur notre tour
[Musique]
et
plus vite
encore pe plus vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore
[Musique]
ti donne-moi
ch on nettoie le mécanisme des portes on
prépare l'ascenseur pour 9h30 pour les
clients donc on contrôle on enlève le le
sable les gravier pour et on va
contrôler que la porte fonctionne
bien tous les matins avant le départ de
l'ascenseur les ascenseurs depuis que
j'y suis moi la il smé quand même pas
mal sinon il y a TR ascenseurs du sol
qui part du sol pour le public pour les
visiteurs pour le public a tro
ascenseurs qui partent du sol qui vont
jusqu'au deè étage nous nous entretenons
uniquement nos ascenseurs du pilier nord
pilier est pilier
Ouest
[Musique]
tu bouges plus s'il te plaît je bouge
plus
on était sur l'ascenseur Nord on a vu
les distances de des électroément qui
disent à l'ascenseur cabine placée
c'està-dire que sur l'ascenseur il y a
un silet qui dit qu'il est arrivé à
l'étage et sur l'étage il y a un autre
silec pour dire la même chose voilà
surtout très intéressant donc là on va
descendre l'arrêt pour que l'ascenseur
quand il arrive il s'arrête un tout
petit peu plus bas et qu'il soit en face
l'un de l'autre ça vous
va
voilà inissage c'est aussi un bon
essuyage alors les chiffons c'est
primordial parce
que comment on dit
labourage et pâturage sont les deux
Melles de la France disant que ici le
principe que nous avons sur tous les
ascenseurs hydraulique ou celui-ci qui
est plus moderne
électrique nous graissons les paliers n
faisons le graissage des paliers des
différents axes comme vousz pu le voir
ça soit sur les cabines que ça soit sur
le TR ici et à chaque graissage que nous
faisons
hebdomadaire ire ou bimensuel ou
trimestriel ou quoi nous essuillons
toujours les l'excédent de graisse qui
sort d'ù le proverbe un bon graissage
c'est un bon
essuyage notre boulot c'est que les
ascenseurs ils fonctionnent pour ça il y
a les je dirais il y a tous les
graissages quotidien et puis il y a les
sécurités je pense qu'il faut être très
très alerte sur toutes les sécurités
c'est-àdire quand on bouge un ascenseur
faut absolument vérifier qu'il y a
aucune porte ouverte faut absolument
faut tout vérifier donc c'est c'est
quand même un
travail je dirais intéressant et qui est
aussi faut pas faire faut pas faire de
conneries quoi la Tourel quand on est
mécano ou quand on est serruer qu'on est
appelé à à à à gérer les ascenseurs et à
gérer du public faut faut être faut être
clair quoi nous arrivons à l'an 2000 et
nous sommes dans la technologie de l'an
2000 tout a été modernisé nous avons des
ordinateurs nous avons des automates
nous avons des visus fallit se mettre un
petit peu à la
[Musique]
couleement je suis pas en
jupe
[Musique]
quand j'ai commené à travailler à la
tour c'était j'ai pas su tout de suite
que c'était la tour cé une petite
annonce c une petite annonce je venais
de je travaille sur le tradero serruier
toujours et j'en avais marre vraiment
Mar céit une petite société et je l une
petite Ann cherche ser d'urgence et on
me donne rendez-vous au pilier nord de
la tour j'y vais confiant moi je me dis
c'est une société extérieure qui qui
embauche pour des travaux sur le site et
quand on m'a dit que Ctait pour la T
j'aurais été capable de signer n'importe
quoi en fin de compte je crois que même
j'ai dû signer n'importe quoi c'est que
non j'étais tellement aller le côté
tourfel c'est le monument tout
simplement de la Dame de Fer c'est comme
ça que je l'appelle c'est je vais
utiliser un terme que j'apprécie
beaucoup c'est fort là c'est les
consignes que j'ai reçu hier par mon
chef donc des petits travaux urgents oui
entre guillemets des trucs à faire assez
rapidement quand même qui peuvent gêner
pour la suite des travaux au 2è étage et
puis madame pipi au 3ème parce que elle
peut pas ouvert sur R de l'eau et ça
c'est on les aime bien ilelles sont
gentils avec nous donc on a tendance à
perd vite on veut la
RRE donc ça ça et donc et ben on va
préparer le
tillage ça
toujours ça ça c'est magique jamais
laisser trace de vre passage éviter la
graisse sur les poignets éviter tout ce
qui peut être corp gras quoi pour pour
le touriste faut pas qu'il reparte
mécontent c'est pas possible ça bien
vérifier ce qu'on a à l'intérieur parce
que le fait de monter au deè étage il
nous faut bien 6 7 minutes on arrive
là-haut on commence le travail on s' qu'
nous manque un outil un seul on perd au
moins 5 petites minutes pour assembler
tout ça ça fait déjà 10 15 minutes on
redescend on va chercher un outil qui
nous manque on repère 5 10 minutes ici à
le trouver on remonte on a perdu une
demi-heure pour un outil une demiheure
pour un outil ça c'est pour le deè étage
pour le 3è non la catastrophe
tout à
fait 9h de
matin
la par
touriste
[Musique]
une bombe
magique quand c'est trop
abîmé je viens le soir et je mets une
coche de peinture partout pour tout
cacher quoi
voilà
[Musique]
c'est pas
tropé
mais il suffit qu'il y en a un qui
commence à écrire les autres touristes
il
suivent
[Musique]
catastrophe voyez même
là je suis là depuis le début février
1967 vous avez donc ça va faire 30 ans
et demi de tel voilà et j'ai vu passer
disons non seulement dans les montées
qui est de plus de 5 millions de
personnes de visiteurs par an mais
disons plus ceux qui passent sur la
tourf c'est c'est c'est en restant ici
si vous avez m on visite le
monde la face cachée de
la
alors lesprit clair c'est ce c'est toute
la la partie incendie de la tour fel
donc quand il y a un incendi et que
l'eau elle part c'est c'est ici que çaf
ça part d'ici pour aller bien sûr
partout jusqu'aux machines dans les
étages ça c'est toute notre partie
incendie 6 5 7
[Musique]
alors là par contre je pas ça en dessous
tu pourras pas me suivre c'est pour
rejoindre le pilier
sud un deè tunnel qui se trouve là-bas
mais là à mon avis tu passeras
pas
donc là en fait on va monter auudessus
de l'interre on va faire le premier
panneau audessus de
l'interre qui sont des 400 W 1000
justeess donc les panneaux des 400 W
sont là 1 W entre les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux
[Musique]
voilà je
trempé c'est mouillé ah oui les tuyau
ils sont avec la condensation le froid
c'est je
tremppé bon on va monter dans les
[Musique]
étages
donc là
j'explique vol aggravé d' touriste c'est
euh c'est les petits cadeau surpris
qu'ils se font eux-mêmes sont aperçus
que la pièce était facile à démonter
donc le touriste s'est amusé à le
démonter puis dans la pche ce matin je
viens et j'en met une toute neu voilà
c'est pas bien compliqué mais bon tous
les matins c'est pareil il manque
quelque chose quelque part ça c'est tous
les
jours un petit
peu mais
bon ça permet au bouche à oril de bien
fonctionner à la tourfl j'ai réussi à
voir ça tiens je vais y aller aussi je
vais aller CEI ça et puis voilà ça
ramène du public je sais pas si c'est ça
qui ramène le public mais
bon et le
fameux
chifon j'ai la ch
chance voilà faut que tu te dépêche
avant qu'ils arrivent avant qu'ils
arrivent ouais parce que s'il
s'aperçoivent non mais c'est vrai en
plus s'ils s'aperçoivent que c'est
facile à démonter il le font se gêne
pas voilà le chiffon c'est ça pas
laisser de graisse pas laisser surtout
pas c'est
interdit déjà il y a déjà eu un début de
démontage làdessus
on va dire que le touriste n r service
il nous donne du travail c'est qu'avec
le passage du public on a énormément
énormément de trafic ici donc les portes
les gros les G tout ça ça s'abî à une
vitesse grand V c'est à compter si on
devait faire une moyenne on a à peu près
5 si interventions par semaine sur la
même porte entre le Grou le Pomel qui
cass les carreaux les c'est bon y a de
quoi faire mon premier jour ça été comme
tous les nouveaux qui sont embouchés
qu'ils arrivent à la Tour Effel on leur
fait visiter évidemment les lieux
monument c'est un grand bateau un grand
P de pétrole et c'est immense et même au
bout de 3 4 jours je n'avais encore pas
trouvé mon orientation au deè
étage je montais par le senseur Nord je
le retrouve plus cet ascenseur Nord je
redescendais par un autre par l'Ouest ou
l'est celui qui était en fonctionnement
il fallait quelques jours de repérage
pour ça ça le fait à tout le monde parce
deè nous sommes un petit peu
[Musique]
perd
bonjour c'est ouvert ton
local
bon al tu fais t les compteurs d'eau oui
oui d'ailleurs il y a un problème là
faut que je
regarde quelque chose qui va
pas
il
[Musique]
retourne ce qui me PLA bien c'est faire
ce trajet là de la tour jusqu'ici
surtout quand il fait B un petit bout de
champ de Mars allez
retour je vaisarer de la
peinture à l'âge 18 ans je suis venu
avec Madame donc ma femme enfin tuit pas
encore marié n'est-ce pas et on est venu
oui on a monté que jusqu'au deè étage et
j'avais pas peur du tout déjà c'est que
ma femme elle avait très très peur et je
croyais jamais que j'allais donc rester
ici jusque normalement si tout se passe
bien jusqu'à ma retraite et tu m'as dit
que vous aviez pas pu monter jusqu'au 3è
il pas pu monter jusquau 3è parce que je
pense qu' beaucoup à l'époque n'av pas
deessous que maintenant je monte t les
jeux gratuits c'est le mécanicien qui
l'a
fait si on à moi c'est
pour c'est pour l'appliquer sur des
chariots pour montrer que ça appartient
à la
Torf d'origine c'est quand il a les
grands
travaux ça c'est de de fer
d'origine j'aime
[Musique]
bien une casquette des anciens
liftier maintenant ça ça se plus
donc fais-moi une belle photo là comme
ça regarde avec les
tatouages lunett mais sans mes lunettes
je su encore plus beau
regarde un pe la comme
ça
tour allez la
dernière
pas t
non trucsjà mett que la tête quand je
suis en famille ou avec des amis ou quoi
que ce soit toujours un qui sait que
j'aime pas qu'on parle de mon travail
enfin c'est pas que j'aime pas mais
c'est vra quand tu tu vis tous les jours
tous les jours les jours dans la tour au
bout d'un moment ça te tu vrais bien
respirer quand Mme peu toujours
quelqu'un pour dire tiens il travaille à
la tourff lui poseliui des questions un
truc comme ça donc et l'éternel
recommencement donc c'est vrai que c'est
marrant quelque part parce que il y a
des gens qui te regardent avec des
grands yeux tu es plombier La Tour mais
qu'est-ce que tu peux bien faire en
plomberie il y a que de la ferraille et
c'est vrai c'est l'image que les gens
beaucoup de gens se font de la tour
c'est un L de ferraille c'est tout bon
par contre à côté comme tu as pu réussir
à filmer tout à l'heure il y a pas que
ça d'ailleurs il a de la serrurerie il y
a de la mécanique comment l'électricité
il y a on a pratiquement tous les corps
de métier je pense qu'il y a certains
collègues qui ont dû t'en parler déjà
c'est ça qui est qui est génial ici
combien vous êtes de technicien combien
il y a nous 32 34 et il y a donc 2600000
rivé je sais pas compter hein mais il y
en a de 2600000
voilà alors 2600000 rivé mais qui n'ont
pas été riés ces 2600000 rivés n'ont pas
été mis sur le site ils ont été mis en
atelier à Levallois parce que toutes les
pièces si vous mieux c'est un énorme
mécano hein un Lego comme on dit
maintenant en plastique avant on avait
des mécano en en fer maintenant nous
avons ça en plastique ce ce ce ce fameux
mécano a été construit le Valois dans
les ateliers d' felles et tout ceci
venait morceau par morceau tracté par
des chevaux ou des bœfs sur des chars et
tout et l'anecdote dit que on a monter
deux fois la téfel ce qui est exact
parce qu'il préparait une première
partie il préparit deuxième partie
regarder si l'assemblage correspondait
bien correctement et si c'était parfait
hop on amenait la première partie et
cetera et cetera et cetera c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont mis que 27 mois pour la oui
c'est ça 27 mois pour la
montée
regarde c'est bateau de plaisance là sil
est
beau il y en a des beau sur Oh
j'aimerais bien en avoir un comme ça moi
j'ai la place pour le mettre en face
chez moi ah quand il fais Go c'est super
agréableiv ça l'
moins
comment vous faites en hiver
d'ailleursev on essaie de pas trop y
aller
si faut vraiment qu'il ait des gros
problèmeson on y va quand même que N
arriv de faire des travaux de
remplacement de passer des dans les VO
asenseurs remplacements projecteur
l'hiver les 400 l'iver
[Musique]
dernier c'est vrai que au début faisait
vachement froid aès ça c'est un peu
[Musique]
calmer ENF n pas trop frilleux quand
même m bon ben envoie le dire
il y partout l'autre côté c'est les
lumières de la tour qui les attirent
donc euh bah ils rentrent un peu puis
après ils ont du mal à repartir
ouais c'est l'époque où il commence à
émigrer là oh ben il y a beaucoup ils
vont mourir là ouais on essaie de les
faire partir mais on a du mal à les
attraper
tous mignon
hein il a même pas peur là il se demande
ce qui lui arrive il dit plus
rien on va le relâcher plus bas parce
que comme ça il va pouvoir partir ah
peutêtre qu'il y en a qui sera
sauvé bon ça ça fait pas partie de notre
travail quand même
[Musique]
normalement sur
mon
[Musique]
R
[Applaudissements]
c'est appréciable à un point incroyable
la scène quand on regarde bien dans le
fond on la voit encore courir sa vers
l'ouest Normandie là va se jeter près de
chez Papa Maman où ils ont une petite
maison l'Arc de Triomphe tous ces
monuments tout c'est ça c'est on
apprécie mieux Paris et la fête à neneux
on a même la fête à neneux d'ici non non
c'est
c'est jamais j'aurais même rêvé de
travailler ici jamais et en fin de
compte maintenant j suis je lâ pas non
non c'est c'est un privilège le travail
mais on travaille partout dans n'importe
quelle société mais c'est un privilège
voilà ça je vois pas une autre société
la chance
de bon ben je vais m mettre je vais
continuer parce qu'il faut peut-être
essayer de finir ce soir
alors hier j'étais en train de faire ce
que vous voyez
là il y a des gens des
Chinois parla chinois mais bien sûr
chinois il m' demandé pouv ils ont pris
le pinceau ils ont commencé à faire
pareil alors moi j'étais un peu plus
loin j'ai regarda les gens il prenaient
des photos et tout enfin ça don 5
minutes comme ça et
après bah je suis venu voir là le
travail va je suis pas méchant mais
j'étais obligé de le refaire et ben
voilà il y a des petits trucs comme ça
il y a des gens qui filment il y a des
gens qui prennent des
photos alors là c'est le bureau de
Monsieur gust F il y a des gens qui
m'ont demandé si c'est le vrai c'est si
ce qui
bouge dis non non c'est un mannequin
tout semble ah bon ou alors des moments
je dis oui c'est un vrai c'est moi qui
lui donne à manger de temps en temps il
y a des gens aussi qui demandent est-ce
qu'on peut aller plus haut
on est déjà au 4e
là oh là c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
raté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est des
phénomènes les gens il viennent il
viennent c'est pour visiter pour aller
sur le monument et tout mais ils ne
savent pas la caverne d'Alibaba qu'il y
a dans les dans les sous-sols dans dans
les
pieds avec 16 m de piston on monte
l'ascenseur de 124 m donc ça ça date de
1890 c'est une conception gust qui est
quand même remarquable de savoir qu'on
monte l' jusqu'au deuxième étage de la
Tour Effel qu'avec de l'eau après on a
un système hydraulique qui sert à faire
la régulation c'est-à-dire
l'accélération la décélération les
différence de charge mais on monte
l'ascenseur à vide jusqu'au deème étage
qu'avec de l'eau et ça ça date de de 105
106 ans les gens pose beaucoup de
questions sur la tour parce que parce
que c'est c'est une intrigue en fait
c'est une intrigue les questions qui
reviennent souvent c'est est-ce que la
tour elle est elle est sur de l'eau
est-ce que la tour de combien elle bouge
on entend des fois qu'elle bouge de 3 m
là-haut je veux dire nous qui sommes de
la Tour Eiffel ça nous fait rire ça nous
fait rire parce que là on voit on est
dans dans les fondations de la tour et
on voit bien c'est du dur donc les gens
qui disent qu'elle est sur de l'eau sur
du mercure ou sur des verrains c'est
faux et ça nous nous qui sommes on monte
des fois dans l'ascenseur et on entend
les gens parler c'est vrai que ça nous
fait rire et et voilà quoi la tour c'est
tout ça c'est aussi plein de plein de
super cherie qu'on entend sur la
tour
[Musique]
les gens sont intrigués de nous voir
dans un accumulateur ils sont quand même
assez intrigués ils se demandent ce il
le voit monter il le voit descendre mais
c'est tout quoi il s'imagine pas
qu' qu'une personne un ouvrier un
ouvrier ou c'est ce qu'on est puisse
rentrer à l'intérieur s'imagine
[Musique]
pas je vais suif je vais mettre le suif
sur
sur la colonne là pour éviter les fuits
[Musique]
d'eau maintenant on a décharger ces
accumulateurs un petit peu mais ça
correspond toujours à peu près à 70 % de
la force motrice à l'heure actuelle
quand même he on se sert toujours de ces
accumulateur haute pression pour le
fonctionnement des ascenseurs malgré la
modernisation qui il y a eu de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour Je te me dis quand on
part c'est bon tu le redescends au sol
et en même temps on regarde avant de le
on a un petit peu de temps avant de le
donner on regarde juste les connexions
on
satque bibi tu m'as reçu
[Musique]
ou je travaillé chez doc des alcool
avant d'arriver à la tourfl une filiale
de chez Total et elle fermait elle
partait au Havre donc moi j'avais pas du
tout envie d'aller au Havre c'est pas
vraiment une ville qui m'intéressait et
donc j'ai envoyé des candidature et
j'avais vu une petite annonce sur le
Parisien cherche mécanicien mais
vraiment la toute petite annonce
insignifiant mais j'ai quand même écrit
et j'ai eu un coup de téléphone de
Monsieur Foray qui me disait
euh si ça me dérangeait de travailler un
weekend sur deux je dis non dit de faire
des soirées j'ai dit non et puis il me
dit faudrait venir à donc vous
connaissez la tourelle j'ai dis oui il
me dit vous venez vous mettez face au
pilier nord et moi je m'attendais qu'il
me dise il y a un grand bâtiment sur la
droite c'est là alors j'attendais
j'attendais je dis oui mais où il me dit
bah au pilier nord c'est là moi dans ma
tête toute la nuit je disais qu'est-ce
qu'on peut bien faire à la tour je
voyais pas du tout ce qu'on pouvait
faire je suis venu et donc il y a eu le
premier l' le le premier entretien on
m'a expliqué donc les inconvénients de
la tour qu'il y a pas de weekend qu'il y
a pas de euh Noël jour de l'an tout on
peut travailler t ces jourslà et et donc
on a discuté de tout ce qu'on discute
dans une embauche et moi en partant je
me dis ouais je vais quand même accepter
parce qu'au moins il y a un truc c'est
sûr c'est que là on va pas me dire c'est
ça déménage ça va au Avre j'étais sûr de
au moins que ça ça m'arriverait pas il
la tour elle risqueit pas de fairemer
aussitôter
l' ça c'est une c'est une vidange ça
vidange les les spring clair la tuyterie
qui qui alimente les spring clair donc
comme il reste toujours un petit peu
d'eau
dedans on
vidange on va la laisser comme ça on
ferme
r je supporte plus les escaliers on a ça
ici que des
escaliers
[Musique]
restaurant Altitude 85 on est où
ici dans Le Rest ENF relever le compteur
de de l'altitude 95 du restaurant c'est
le alimentation en eau chaude en e glacé
pour enfin tout le système de
refroidissement climatisation tout ce
qu'on veut il y a plein de plein de Ch
je suis encore en admiration il y a des
fois il y a des coins que je connais pas
que je découvre et je me dis en moi-même
c'est un beau tas de ferraille qui est
très bien
[Musique]
empilé
là on va aller voir de loin ceuxl rouge
comme ça
60 km on les
voitter va seever au
[Musique]
vent
bon
voilà c'est beau c'est
rouge quand on est comme ça il
autour les bâtiments qui sont haut et
sont très très loin donc ça fait encore
plus l'impression de vide
hein ouais question de hauteur en tant
que menusier charpentier monter sur des
toits 10 m il y avait pas plus de risque
même là à 50 m même jusqu'à 100 m si on
tombe on tombe on est mort tout façon à
10 m ou à j'ai eu des collègue de
travail ils tombent mais sont non ils
sont pas remontés la première il faut
pas avir le vertige premièrement parce
que ça ça se contrôle pas le vertige
vous l' en montant sur une chaise en
montant sur un escabau je suis monté
dans la ferraille ce qu'on appelle
monter dans la ferraie que être obligé
d'aller dans la structure pour aller
chercher n'importe quoi et moi ce
jour-là je me souviens c'était un
morceau de fer du fer cornière qui était
en train de se détacher sous le deuxème
étage c'est un collègue à moi qui qui
était préposé à y aller
et bon je savais que j'avais pas le
vertige puisque j'ai père qui était
couvreur mais je voulais quand même m'en
rendre compte par moi-même alors je lui
ai demandé je fa est-ce que je peux
venir avec toi alors il m'a demandé t'as
jamais escaladé j'ai dit non c'est la
première fois mais je veux savoir
comment ça fait alors bon il m'a dit
d'accord on a mis une ceinture et tout
j'y suis allé et c'est vrai que c'est
très impressionnant la première fois tu
as pratiquement 200 m de vide en dessous
toi tu marches sur des morceaux de fer à
peu près 5 cm 5 6 cm de de large tu te
demandes si ça va tenir au début tu as
les jambes qui commencent à faire un
petit pe ça puis bon je pense que c'est
ma nature je suis pas attiré par le vide
donc après ça a été tout seul on pas
l'habitude d'escalader comme ça moi
j'étais à même le sol là je me retrouve
faire de la ferraille à 320 m bon
ça la peur elle passe le côté fierté
faut dire ce qu' est quand on a nos
ceintures moi quand je vois les
électriciens partir avec le gros sac à
dos et les ampoules derrière je dis
chapeau les sacs à dos on les a eu parce
que bon on a commencé à travailler sur
les illuminations quand ça a été créé
bientôt 10 ans maintenant
oui bah
monte donc on s'est dit benah on est
embêé pour porter les ampoules et on a
eu l'idée après tout que de les prendre
sur soir les metteit dans notre chemise
et tout on va essayer d'acheter les sac
à dos donc on a été à la Samaritaine
acheter les premiers sac à deau voilà et
ces sacs à doau là ils ont vécu parce
que à force de mettre des balases dedans
ils se sont déchirés et tout donc après
on a commandé des plus sérieux matériel
d'alpiniste
[Musique]
oui bien qu'est-ce que tu vas faire là
bah là on va essayer de monter fa les
cheîn nous au premier étage donc je vais
chercher ma centure de sécurité je vais
essayer de trouver mon collègue et on y
va ma petite collection de des
autocollants que les touristes ils
collent sur la ferraille à la tourfelle
et moi je vais par derrière je les
enlève tout doucement et je les colle
là tu es prête ou
oui je suis prête salut salut ça va sais
qu'elle est prête
broche vas-y tu évite de parler en
espagnol tu vas comme ça oui pourquoi
tuène pas de manteau à rien non je l'
enlever bon c'est bon pourquoi bah c'est
fait froide sur le coup si siige maladie
si des fois ilige tu tombes pas en
maladie il a raison il est prévenant
c'est un très bon camarade va allez-y
c'est un très bon camarade de travail
couvre-toi
oua au niveau des miches parce que tu es
un peu
platarrière un
cinéma tombe
[Musique]
bien chercher sac
c'est bien ça mais je dirais pas ce que
ça
fait attends
[Musique]
atts
qu'est-ce qu'on fait nettoyer on nettoie
oui en fait il y a une routière là et on
est en train de
nettoyerach je vou voir vous voulez voir
on se penche un peu que la ceinture
regardez
oui oui mais il n'avait que ça ça ça
s'appelle une roulette de ENF une
roulette de ligne de
vie qui roule comme ça je peux je peux
meacer comme je veux sans
tomber ser toujours accroché je pensais
que vous aviez peut-être des chaussures
à crampon ch de
Mar ça gouttière
Chau
c'est pas dangereux en fait il ont plus
que nous mon
avisu quand depuis combien de temps vous
faites ce métier moi je travaille à la
Tour depuis 18
ans
[Musique]
habite c'est
inroyable avec comme
ça tour comme ça ou tout tourour et les
deux étages deè étage dernier
aussi c'est prier deè pr de et vous
avancez avec des petits trucs comme ça
voilà il
C et tu avances comme ça avec le comme
ça avec la rette donc on risque rien
même moi je me serai attaché
iciou je me attaché à tous les trucs
comme
ça es
prête
doucement c'est lour ah oui je
sais machiniste tu faais c'était quoi là
je conduisais carrément les
ascenseurs ben on montait carrément avec
l'ascenseur c'est on le faisait marcher
carrément c'est nous qui on le faisait
monter au
premier vous étiez où dans la cabine que
vous avez dû filmer à un moment donné
oou un autre ou il y a un mannequin B le
mannequin avant c'était
moi
en cher et en os j'ai
conduit bon c'est pas la conduite d'un
véhicule et tout il y av pas de repère
il y pasutant de sécurité qu' a
maintenant la sécurité c'était que l qui
s'allumait dans voir en disant tiens les
portes sont ferm ferm une autre lampe
qui vous disait que lesèr étaient fermé
et alors nous avions notre fameux volant
on tourne à droite ça monte on tourna à
gauche ça descendait et c'était nous qui
nous avions des marques le long de la
voie des traits rouges des trait blancs
et puis après de rouges de blancs pour
s'arrêter et poil à l'étage voilà et les
sensations génialand dans la Quand tu es
dans la raconte-moi géni oh mais non ça
ser RAC pas parce que c'est génial c'est
des sensations que tu ressens à
l'intérieur de toi c'est c'est super tu
montes avec l'ascenseur tu es tout seul
en plus c'est super bien non là je peux
pas le raconter ça faut l'avoir vécu et
je le je le verrai plus malheureusement
maintenant très important là à
moi que je le verrai plus maintenant ah
bah ils ont tout
automatisé c'est
progrès bientôt vont automatiser mon
Albert pour nettoyer les
[Musique]
chaînau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
can amorceur et là-bas tous les coups
c'est pareil alors ah ous ont déjà Moné
ceux VO s s pas pas am de toute façon
c'est pas cet armir là c'est l'autre ou
où est-ce qu'on est ici B on est sur la
passage technique du premier étage là où
on a les armoir électriqu TGBT tout ce
qui est technique l'extérieur les tour
souvent la tour fel ouais il y a des
ascenseurs il y a des agents d'accueil
mais il pense pas que tout ça ça demande
de l'entretien ça demande des
électriciens des gens qui s'occupent de
clim même des menuisiers ou des
plombiers je crois qu'ils s'en rendent
pas compte que en fait la tour c'est un
petit village c'est un petit village il
y a beaucoup de monde qui travail plein
de choses par exle aujourd'hui on va
faire l'illumination demain on va être
sur un ascenseur ouais c'est sûr en fait
on fait plein de choses différentes mê
ch on est très polyvalent en fait il
faut être polyvalent je crois ah tout le
monde n'est pas égo c'est sûr tout le
monde n'est pas pareil mais en principe
les gens qui travaent au service
électrique surtout sont polyvalents
cherche quoi un
amorceur tu chos comme ça voilà cherche
ça il y en a pas fa va falloir
redescendre on en a qu'un
seul c'est le fameux ne rien oublier ne
rien n mettre
c'est ça voilà la preuve elle est
[Musique]
là si nous mettions la tffelle dans un
bocal
mieux donc il fait 175 m de diamètre
puisquentre chaque pilier en ligne
droite nous avons d'une arête à l'autre
extérieure 125 m donc le diamètre ça
fait 175 m sur 300 m de haut ça crée un
certain volume exa il faut faire le
calcul je l'ai plus en tête un volume
d'air et C A qui est contenu
dans Comment dir dans ce bcal de 175 m
de diamètre par m de haut l'air qui est
compintérieur de ce bocal là est plus
lourd que la
tourfelle ah oui oui oui fait Calc
pardon venir avec sa clé du
TGBT
merci on m'envoie un électricien pour
m'ouvrir le local voilà vous remarquez
le monde qu' a là on est lundi le mardi
il y a tous les musées de Ferm donc le
double le double d'aller voir le musée
fermé c'est pas possible donc ils
viennent tous ici c'est l'enfer ça c'est
a l'ambiance quoi il chante il dan
avancez bien au fond s'il vous
plaît on avance au fond s'il vous
plaît
[Musique]
aveci av bien le fond s'il vous
plaît
ch
ben j'ai même pas le bon modèle je vais
être obligé de redescendre voilà gagné
un quart d'heure m de perdu dit quand on
travaille la TFEL c'est qu'on pas la
TFEL alors bien sûr qu'est-ce que tu
fais je pas la TFEL dit qu temps écoute
quand on commence par le haut on arrive
en bas on recommence après voilà ça fait
30 ans que je PES la
tourelle donc en fait de la peinture il
y a trois couleurs différentes il y a
des numéros numéro 1 numéro 2 et numéro
3 numéro 1 c'est à partir de premier
étage au sol les quatre pieds c'est
numéro 1 de premier étage au 2e c'est
numéro 2 et du 12e jusqu'au 3e c'est
numéro 3 ça veut dire qu'il a une
différence de ton donc là je vais faire
un peu de de la peinture numéro 2 voilà
c'est c'est c'est la peinture spécial
que c'est fabriqué spécial tel ça veut
dire qu'il y a qu'une couche tous les
tous les 7 ans donc là je vais faire des
petits
trucs la
lumière
voilà surveilleer la mécanique et tout
le système électrique du R chaussée au
2è du 2e au 3e du 3e au premier c'est
fou la nuit comme elle brille plus belle
qu'un Barille et c'est nous qui avons
les clés du plus fou dessous de tout le
monde entier nous sommes des istrions
des artistes funambul ne cherchez pas le
vestibule il n'y a que du vent dans
toute la maison nous sommes des
papillons pris dans ces jolis dentelles
Paris s'veille tout en bas Paris ne nous
voit pas sur notre
[Musique]
tour bien sûr il y a les touristes les G
puis les gens tristes et ceux qui vont s
pass dans l'ombre des piliers près des
sorties de secou nous travaillons très à
l'aise au milieu des japonaises
lorsquentre deux ascenseurs elles ont
pris notre cœur pour lui parler d'amour
nous sommes des istrions des artistes
funambul ne cherchez pas le vestibule il
n'y a que du vent dans toute la maison
nous sommes les papillons pris dans ces
jeolie dentelle Paris s'éveille tout en
bas Paris ne nous voit pas sur notre
tour et felle
au revoir